[Música]
pero amanece este lunes con un vacío de
poder sin presidente de la república
tras la renuncia de manuel merino el
congreso no ha logrado aún un acuerdo
para un presidente interino luego de
rechazar el nombramiento de la
izquierdista rocío silva el parlamento
convocó a una nueva sesión este día
tenemos reporte desde la imagen brasil
celebró ayer elecciones municipales y la
derecha moderada derrotó a los
candidatos apoyados por el presidente
ultraderechista ya ir bolsonaro la
mayoría de las grandes capitales le
dieron la espalda al mandatario en unos
comicios que fueron postergados por la
pandemia por la que se esperaba poca
afluencia pero la participación superó
el 77% comienza en francia el juicio por
un atentado frustrado en el 30 dice en
2015 un marroquí junto a otros tres
hombres que presuntamente le brindaron
apoyo son juzgados en parís ayuda el
kazan y consiguió herir a dos pasajeros
antes de ser desarmado por militares
estadounidenses que viajaban en el tren
hola bienvenidos a las noticias en
france 24 mi nombre es alan austria la
empresa farmacéutica moderna ha
anunciado que la vacuna que está
desarrollando contra el coronavirus
tiene una efectividad del 90 y 4.5 por
ciento y que además cumple los criterios
de eficacia exigidos para su
comercialización según su comunicado en
el que afirma que es un gran día en la
lucha contra la pandemia puesto que se
ha cumplido con los criterios
establecidos en el protocolo para
estudiar su eficacia y que en los
próximos días presentará la
documentación para su aprobación
definitiva minutos antes el director de
la ms pedrosa danón había advertido que
una vacuna sola no será suficiente para
frenar la pandemia
nos vamos a perú y es que el país inicia
este lunes con un vacío de poder sin
presidente de la republica y sin mesa
directiva del congreso tras la renuncia
este domingo de manuel merino presidente
en transición empujado a dimitir por la
presión de los ciudadanos en las calles
en unas movilizaciones y presentes horas
después de su salida a las 9 bancadas
del congreso comenzaron a negociar quien
asumirá la presidencia del legislativo y
que será también quien asuma la jefatura
de estado pero el congreso no alcanzó el
consenso y este bloqueo generó nuevas
protestas en las calles ahora el
legislativo tiene previsto reunirse
nuevamente para desatascar la votación
tras rechazar el nombramiento de la
izquierdista rocío silva santisteban que
se espera de esta sesión y de la jornada
de hoy nos respondió nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
buenos días sido en medio de la
incertidumbre los ciudadanos hasta ahora
no entienden como el país salió de un
mal gobierno para entrar a un
desgobierno sin jefe que facturen el
parlamento y sin presidente que gobierna
esta nación los ciudadanos van a tener
mucha expectativa a la jornada que se va
a realizar el día de hoy el congreso ha
citado a las dos de la tarde para una
nueva sesión de balotaje de la que se
espera salga el nuevo presidente de este
país y asimismo las nuevas autoridades
que van a regir el poder legislativo
para ponerle más suspenso a la cosa el
tribunal constitucional señaló que hoy
también me iba a revisar la demanda
competencial interpuesta por el
presidente martín vizcarra para algunos
juristas y otros especialistas en la
materia si es que el tribunal
constitucional emite una sentencia a
favor del exmandatario martín vizcarra
en la cual
es podría señalar que el congreso
sobrepasó sus facultades de relación con
el ejecutivo las cosas podrían retornar
a martín vizcarra nuevamente al poder
fácil celebró este domingo elecciones
con casi 148 millones de ciudadanos
convocados a votar por más de 5.500
puestos municipales la mayoría de las
grandes ciudades le dieron la espalda a
los candidatos apoyados por el
presidente del país el ultraconservador
jair bolsonaro y favorecieron a los
aspirantes del centro y la derecha
moderada veamos el informe de marina
sardiña brasil llevó a cabo su elección
más inusual desde el retorno de la
democracia en 1985 con el obligado uso
de mascarillas y el gel desinfectante
como protagonistas la pandemia de kobe
19 marcó los comicios municipales del
domingo aplazados varias semanas por el
virus que deja casi 6 millones de
contagios en el país creo que la
política siempre es importante
independientemente de que estamos
viviendo una situación de pandemia la
gente siempre tiene que ejercer el
derecho al voto
la votación por la que se designan a los
cinco mil 569 alcaldes y concejales
municipales de la mayor economía de
américa latina es también un pulso a las
políticas del presidente yair bolsonaro
que pondrán a prueba la fuerza del giro
a la derecha de la nación y que según
adelantan los analistas será una
victoria para los conservadores con una
gran cantidad de candidatos evangélicos
y ex integrantes de las fuerzas de
seguridad brasileñas por su parte el ex
vicepresidente izquierdista luiz inácio
lula da silva arremetió contra
visionario bolsonaro bolsonaro es
posiblemente el mayor desastre político
del país creo que en muchos años a
partir de ahora alguna milicia algunos
fanáticos pueden inventar algo útil que
evolucionar o hizo por el país la
jornada transcurrió con dificultades en
el estado norteño de amapá debido al
racionamiento de luz y con la mitad del
electorado tras un aplazamiento de los
comicios en la capital la capa por
cuestiones de seguridad
el huracán yo está se fortalece y
llegará esta noche a centroamérica entre
categoría 4 y 5
los meteorólogos advierten que yota
continua mostrando signos de
fortalecimiento en momentos en que la
región aún sufre los estragos causados
por el huracán eta los gobiernos de
nicaragua y honduras indicaron que ya
están evacuando a algunas personas en
áreas cercanas a la frontera que
comparte una región que según los
pronósticos se encuentra en la
trayectoria del huracán sus vientos
máximos sostenidos son de 155 kilómetros
por hora y ahora se desplaza hacia el
archipiélago colombiano de san andrés
providencia y santa catalina a una
velocidad de 15 kilómetros por hora
y finalizamos en francia- ayub el kazan
y comparece ante la justicia desde este
lunes acusado de intento de atentado
terrorista en el 30 list en 2015 que fue
frustrado por militares estadounidenses
que estaban en el tren el marroquí de 31
años será juzgado por una corte en parís
us del 17 de diciembre junto a otros
tres hombres que presuntamente le
brindaron apoyo desde la capital
francesa a erika olavarría nos dio
detalles del frustrado ataque y del
proceso actual
hola buenas tardes alan bueno gracias
sobre todo al heroísmo de los pasajeros
de ese tren había 750 250 solamente en
ese carro donde estaba
alcázar y recordemos que cuando él sale
del baño de ese está lisa armado con un
fusil de asalto con 300 municiones con
un cuchillo y con una pistola en el
bolsillo dos pasajeros un francés y un
franco estadounidense lo detienen
intentan controlarlo de hecho uno de
ellos le quita el fusil pero al cazan y
sacó un arma que tiene el bolsillo lo
hiere gravemente y ahí es cuando llegan
los famosos estadounidenses esos tres
amigos de la infancia dos de ellos
militares que logran definitivamente
controlarlos pero en esa pelea alcanzan
y saca un cuchillo que tiene en el
bolsillo y viene y era uno de ellos
finalmente logran amarrarlo con las
corbatas de los pasajeros y uno de los
militares además ayudó a la persona que
había quedado gravemente herida hasta la
llegada de los servicios de urgencia
ellos los tres estadounidenses que
recibieron la legión de honor de parte
del presidente françois hollande y que
luego se convirtieron a la ciudadanía
francesa también que ya no son más
soldados que son prácticamente
personalidades
en eeuu ellos van a participar de este
juicio van a venir al final de esta
semana porque quieren ver dijeron los
ojos de la persona quienes ellos
lograron controlar ese terrible día de
agosto del año 2015
alan también debía participar clint
eastwood recordemos que él hizo una
película que fue protagonizada por los
mismos jóvenes pero no ha respondido a
la convocatoria llegamos al final de
esta emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía les recordamos la información
no se detiene con actualizaciones
constantes aquí en nuestra señal
televisiva e información al momento en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom y en
nuestras redes sociales
muchas gracias nuevamente por su
compañía siga con nosotros y disfrute de
su día
[Música]
bienvenidos